This is my city, where no sunset is
like the previous one, where the seashore of the bay, the
first beach, the third beach, lie down, my
best friends, where is the salted beef, whether it is
fried or in a tomato. This is my Berdyansk. And
this is his soul.
near it
grew its own, the city began from the
Cossack industries on the spit and, of course, from
Port, which opened new trade routes
, more than ten European consulates appeared in the city,
ships were drawn here,
different people were drawn here, they built their churches, built
synagogues, kirki nassi here
became local here  began to complain
about tourists, you hear this is Berdyansk
and its sounds, its summer, festivals
in the summer, there are many things to do in the evening, go to the
embankment, but so as
not to run into people, mosquitoes, and what without people, you
need to go to the spit And in general, if you have not visited
the spit, then  March spent the summer. Also, you can
track jellyfish in chats, but mosquitoes
and jellyfish are better than invaders, even though they
don’t steal blenders and edits. This is my miss  and these are
his people, we have peace until you come,
believe us, in February itself, they will
pay for it, but they do not give up, despite the
collaborators in power, they go to the rally
in full voice and declare which
they happily watch as the
Russian ship burns and show Ukraine to the
world that it is in resistance  there is no age and you are my
Berdians scattered around the world like splashes of a
sea wave, they are eagerly waiting
for the light of the lighthouse on the far spit to shine again on the horizon for them,
how they will feel the
taste of Victory, it will be salty from the tears
and the salted bull of the breadwinner, like next
to the monuments to the boy fisherman of
greed  and plumbing will see the new
women who courageously reprimand the invader and the
boys with the Ukrainian flag,
how they will go to a drunken party, where is the Brod museum.
mosquito jellyfish and
chests full of Freedom will breathe the sea
because they are part of it This is my B
Erdyansk is Ukraine